and finally new rule if you're part of
today's woke Revolution you need to
study the part of revolutions where they
spin out of control because the
revolutionaries get so drunk on their
own purifying Elixir they imagine they
can reinvent the very nature of human
beings
[Applause]
communist communist thought selfishness
selfishness could be cast out of human
nature Russian revolutionaries spoke of
the new Soviet man who wasn't motivated
by self-interest but instead wanted to
be part of a collective
no turns out he wanted to be on a yacht
in a Gucci tracksuit holding a vodka and
a prostitute
[Applause]
not standing in line all day for a
potato
the problem with Communism and with some
very recent ideologies here at home is
that they think you can change Reality
by screaming at it that you can bend
Human Nature by holding your breath but
that's the difference between reality
and your mommy
one said that you can repeal all past
history but you still cannot repeal
Human Nature but he's canceled now so
him
[Applause]
GPT are there any similarities between
today's woke Revolution and Chairman
Mao's cultural revolution of the 1960s
and it wrote back how long do you have
because again in China we saw how a
revolutionary thought he could do a page
one rewrite
of humans Mao ordered his citizens to
throw off the four olds old thinking old
culture old customs and old habits so
um your whole life went in the garbage
overnight no biggie
and those who resisted were attacked by
an army of purifiers called the Red
Guard who went around the country
putting dunce caps on people yeah who
didn't take to being a new kind of
mortal being a lot of pointing and
shaming went on Oh and about a million
dead and the only way to survive was to
plead Insanity for the crime of being
insufficiently radical then apologize
and thank the state for the chance to
see what a piece of you are
and of course submit to re-education or
as we call it here in America freshman
orientation
[Applause]
listen to this story there's a law
professor at the University of Illinois
Chicago named Jason Kilbourne whose
crime was that on one of his exams he
used a hypothetical case or a black
female worker sued her employer for race
and gender discrimination alleging that
managers had called her to slur words
the type of real world case these
students might one day confront and
knowing the extreme sensitivity of
today's students he didn't write the two
taboo words on the test just the first
letter of each he was teaching his
students how to fight racism in the
place where it matters most the criminal
justice system but because he merely
alluded to those words again in the
service of a good cause he was banned
from campus placed on indefinite leave
and made to wear the duns cap
no not really the duns cap part but but
our American version of that eight weeks
of sensitivity training weekly 90-minute
sessions with a diversity trainer and
having to write five self-reflection
papers a grown ass man
a liberal law professor if you can't see
the similarities between that and this
the person who needs re-education is you
yes we we do have our own Red Guard here
but they do their rampaging on Twitter
here's a cute example from a couple of
years ago the banjo player
from Mumford and Sons tweeted that he
liked a book A book that apparently had
not been approved by the revolution
so of course he had to delete the Tweet
then take time away from the band oh my
God you mean this could have affected
Mumford and Sons
and then the cringing apology I have
come to better understand the pain
caused by the book I endorsed pain
from a book unless he hit the drummer
over the head with it
what happened to I can read whatever the
I want
[Applause]
don't worry I'm a musician it won't
happen again
[Music]
there was once a very different musician
named John Lennon who wrote a song
called Revolution and people who didn't
really listen to it thought it was a
rah-rah call for revolution no it was
the opposite the lyrics are you say you
want a revolution well you know we all
want to change the world
but if you go carrying pictures of
Chairman Mao you ain't gonna make it
with anybody anyhow
there's a guy who understood how good
intentions can turn into the insane
arrogance of thinking your Revolution is
so awesome and your generation
is so mind-bendingly improved that you
have bequeathed the world with a new
kind of human you're welcome
foreign
[Applause]
with Communists that human was no longer
selfish
in America today that human is no longer
born male or female
and obesity is not something that
affects Health you can be healthy at any
size really we voted on it
[Applause]
formerly serious magnet magazine last
year published with a straight face an
article called separating Sports by sex
doesn't make sense
yes it does
because again we haven't reinvented Homo
sapiens since Crystal Pepsi came out
I've spent three decades on TV mocking
Republicans who said climate change was
just a theory and now I got to deal with
people who say you know what else is
just a theory biology